the Seawork fish factory in Walvis Bay  on Namibia's Atlantic coast is an  example of how the country's government  wants to shape the economy the catch is  processed here instead of being exported  for processing elsewhere that means  higher revenue and more jobs 1,500  people currently work at the factory  along with building up the production  sector and boosting mining  infrastructure is high on the agenda  Namibia plays an important role as a  transit route for the landlocked  countries in the interior of the  continent and the plans go beyond that  among the goals of vision 2030 is to  create 109 thousand new jobs and build  185 thousand affordable homes the  government also says it aims to reduce  social inequality but the country's  underdeveloped education system could be  a stumbling block to reach its ambitious  goals Namibia needs skilled workers it's  trying to meet the challenge by  investing in education currently to the  tune of 1 billion euros a year